[Music]
that's crazy yeah speak of the devil and
he will come yeah Federico was just
telling me all about your night last
night you you left a lot out what I mean
I was telling her how much fun we had
last night yeah
and Tommy made new friends yeah he said
you weren't even buying drinks by the
other night never get that buddy bye to
you at the bartender when we go out I
guess I mean they just love Americans
here hmm what do you think right what
are you uh you doing here Federico was
nice enough to come make us dinner
Emilio gotcha Torah God rabbit stew uh
it's not a chicken piccata I know but
then I speak with you for a second
inside of course I was about to ask you
to help me decide the table
I think this is the place
welcome home better than your head time
you have all the privacy you could ever
want
it's like we're the only two people in
the room what's wrong I can't stop
seeing you in it cat stop crying you
can't really fix this right we're not
gonna leave until I do
delegating
[Music]
speak of the devil and he will come you
need to leave right now there is another
way it is good to know
he's in there is it my dream you know
what I love about running the hunt
Euler attained I know make it feel safe
and drop snaps
the look in his eyes my
to
[Music]
you